what's with the jeans would you like
care to read some emails yeah hey mommy
Tom and mommy teen a long time listener
lifelong Danny AK here I've got my denim
in a bit of a twist my partner recently
farted during intercourse yeah feel
about it let me be clear this fart came
from Browntown and it smelt like chicken
cream mid flow into relations just want
to get you your guts opinion on the
matter and if coital farts are
acceptable fYI I have also asked Hitler
about this but he hasn't replied to any
of my emails many thanks mr. reckless
eyeballin a bitch well here's the thing
Hitler doesn't answer your emails he
only answers vlogs yeah that's true you
got this yeah that's true that's kind of
some some JV shit too yeah first of all
farts happen in relationship I think we
hold them in during lovemaking yeah I
mean first of all I want to I just want
to clarify I'm pretty sure you're
talking about somebody who accidentally
farted I mean that's a big thing we're
talking right an accidental farty and
disgusting but the the thing I want to
also make clear is as an accidental fart
unless you're a real piece of shit you
forgive an accidental fart yeah it's an
accident yeah now is it acceptable well
it's acceptable that it happened
accidentally you know if it's a repeat
or a deliberate thing that's a different
thing you know yeah you should make
every effort to hold it in your form you
should try to hold in farts I mean look
how long I've been with you I've held in
all those farts I know and I've had to
fart a lot yeah there have been times
where it's come close yeah for sure yeah
down to the fart wire yeah and you still
hold it in yeah I can't you still hold
it I still hold it as well yeah of
course you do fuck my stoma
but do you you still you do then go to
the bathroom and then
but only or I hold it until we're done
oh you say that I have it yeah I mean
I've had them where I go right to the
end flip over and then you know let out
it I know oh I know you and I have been
making sweet marital love and then you
immediately fart after it just made love
and I go I know we're done yeah that's
how you know we're done parts we're done
it's true it means we're totally done
you're totally I can't wait until our
son coz you've been burping in front of
him he's too young to really know what's
happening but when he figures it out
it's gonna be fucking mayhem in this
house yeah I ripped some big burps in
front of him
big what farts to first I don't think
even knows where they come from purpose
he looks at me and I go little jeans is
gonna pick up some bad habits between
between mom and dad we're gonna get a
lot of phone calls I'm your son and he
farted and then he said dammit I wish I
had burp at the same time I would be
like well yeah it's a pretty big deal
when you do that